اول مركز محافظه استطاعت القوات الروسيه
السيطره عليه خلال حربها على اوكرانيا حتى
الان
انطلقت الدبابات والمدرعات الروسيه من شبه
جزيره القرم في يوم الحرب الاول وعبر جسر
انطونيوسكي على نهر دينيبرو ودخلت مدينه
خيرسون
[موسيقى]
بهجوم مضاد استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه
الجسرى في اليوم الثاني لكن القوات
الروسيه استطاعت محاصره المدينه مجددا الى
ان سقطت تحت سيطرتها في الثاني من اذار
مارس
شهدت اطراف المقاطعه بعدها مناوشات كثيره
ومع اعتماد كلا الطرفين على القصف بعيد
المدى كان تزويد الولايات المتحده لكياب
لمنظومه صواريخ هاي مارس منتصف العام
الماضي نقطه فاصله في المعركه في نهايه
اغسطس شنت القوات الاوكرانيه هجوم مضاده
كبيرا بالتزامن مع اعلان موسكو عن استفتاء
انتهى الى ضم خرسون ومقاطعات اخرى الى
الاتحاد الروسي تواصل القصف العنيف بين
الطرفين واستخدمت روسيا في تكتيكاتها
سلاحا جديدا هو الطائرات المسيره
الانتحاريه التي تقول كياف انها ايرانيه
على الجانب الاخر كانت مدرعات بيبر
الالمانيه الحامله للجسور عنصرا مهما في
تعزيز قدره الجيش الاوكراني على عبور
الانهار والقنوات المائيه الكثيره في
المقاطعه خلال المعارك في التاسع من
نوفمبر اعلنت قوات الروسيه انسحابها وتم
تفجير الجسور بين ضفتين نهر عقب ذلك
قال الكريم ان موسكو ما تزال تعتبر خرسون
ارض الروسيه رغم الانسحاب منها ورغم اعلان
موسكو سحب جميع القوات الا ان اوكرانيا
اعلنت سيطرتها على العديد من المركبات
الثقيله والذخائر التي خلفتها روسيا وقالت
ان كثيرا من الجنود الروس فشلوا في
المغادره واختباوا داخل المدينه بثياب
المدنيه